my first introduction Cahill for college
was my high school literature teacher
brought us to a play here on campus my
step-grandmother who attended Hillsdale
College many many years ago encouraged
me to apply for a job here at Hillsdale
so i did and i started in September
third might consist eh and I started in
the admissions department I work for
Hillsdale College almost 46 years I have
worked for five athletic directors each
one of them has impacted my life to work
for these great men has has just been
wonderful and the student-athletes it's
been so rewarding to watch them grow in
their skill of sport as well as mature
and two fine men and women and it's so
much fun I kept contact with many
coaches and athletes and it's just
really been wonderful well i don't think
i should say a favorite sport I suppose
basketball is my favorite but that might
have to do with the weather up there as
well the whole athletic defense and is
like a family and I have to see the
entire colleges to when there was a need
everyone would pitch him and work
together I really cares about each other
three most important things in my life
face my family and my chosen family it
could be inducted into the Hall of Fame
i still can't quite believe it's
happening i received the letter in the
mail it says congratulations you are
being inducted and of course i had
mailed out that letter for many years to
people I looked at it I put it down and
I looked at it again and I thought I
just can't believe it I'm honored I'm
humbled I'm astounded I just it's just
wonderful it's just wonderful
[Music]
you